le chômage on l'a pas choisi on le subit
c'est les chefs d'entreprise qui
licencie
cueillant notre invité du samedi 20h ce
soir à l'inflora 54 ans
l'un des 400 000 chômeurs en fin de
droit sans revenu de remplacement rien
du tout donc vous touchez tous les mois
entre 420 et 460 euros votre logement
vous coûte 460 euros par mois résultat
une fois logé il ne vous reste rien et
vous nous direz à 20h comment vous
mangez
[Musique]
Alain Florent ce soir on peut parler
politique pendant des heures même
intelligemment et puis il y a la réalité
la vôtre c'est le chômage alors on va
reprendre les choses au départ vous êtes
né à Asnières il y a 54 ans
après votre scolarité vous passez un CAP
de photographie et vous devenez apprenti
ensuite service militaire deux ans à
ECPA service photo et cinéma des armées
jusque là tout va bien dans cette
période là les années 70 tout va bien on
est jeune comme beaucoup de jeunes
aujourd'hui avec beaucoup d'espoir et
puis il y a du travail quoi voilà après
votre service en 1976 vous intégrez le
studio photo du boulevard Haussmann vous
êtes chargé des prises de vue en labo là
vous avez un CDI évidemment tout à fait
à l'époque la précarité c'est un concept
qui n'existe pas c'est clair que bon
l'avenir était on va dire quelque part
annonceur de choses meilleures vécu nos
parents et puis les années passant on
arrive sur les années 2000 et ça change
tout quoi alors à l'époque on change de
boîte pour évoluer pour gagner plus pour
avoir plus de responsabilité c'est ce
qui vous arrive d'ailleurs voilà en 1989
vous entrez au studio 44 à Paris d'abord
vous êtes tireur filtreur puis adjoint
au chef de service et enfin chef du labo
photo exactement à l'époque 50000 balles
par mois quand même exact c'est la bonne
ville j'avais j'étais papa de trois
enfants j'étais marié donc voilà une vie
normale de ce qu'on pourrait être appelé
à vivre toute sa vie quoi c'est pas que
vous consommez vous achetez déjà
mais en 1991 le studio 44 est vendu à
RSCG Eurocom la boîte de Jack Séguéla
vous êtes viré vous le savez pas à ce
moment-là vous avez mangé votre main
blanc c'est-à-dire le meilleur de votre
vie est derrière vous exactement vous
avez aucune notion de sa à l'époque non
parce que je sais pas je suis parti
encore des générations d'après-guerre on
va dire en bout voilà où les valeurs
c'était travailler à l'école
correctement sortir à l'école avec un
bagage plus ou moins important et puis
rentrer dans la vie active et les choses
se déroulaient normalement je veux dire
bon changer de société pour améliorer
ses ressources monter en responsabilité
prendre toujours apprendre pour être
compétitif il y avait envie de réussir
pour vivre décemment avec des revenus
qui vont avec alors vous entrez dans une
agence de presse à Meudon et là
changement de trip quoi vous êtes obligé
de bosser la nuit pour 50% de moins
exactement
on vous fait comprendre que bon vous
voyez bon pour les formations tout ça
vous êtes plus dans le coup quoi
c'est un double peine tout à fait alors
là vous devenez chômeur pour le coup je
rechute encore de 50% des ressources
puisque je tombe je viens je viens
indemniser au titre de retour à l'emploi
donc 57% des revenus d'avant oui alors
quand vous avez la location de retour à
l'emploi ça vous semble normal vous
dites finalement j'ai cotisé pendant des
années après tout maintenant l'état me
rend un peu de pognon pourquoi pas mais
en 2006 quand vous êtes à la location
Spécifique de Solidarité la SS là vous
commencez à flipper parce que là c'est
une un des Mickey un petit peu
humiliante moi j'ai travaillé plus de 30
ans mais là vraiment je vérifie je sais
que j'ai de l'âge j'ai touché le fond
quoi alors en plus ces agents du Pôle
Emploi ils sont incapables de vous aider
à rebâtir un projet professionnel
c'est une visite où
on vous demande effectivement ce que
vous voulez faire quand vous exposez ce
que vous voulez faire on vous tourne
l'écran vous dit voyez actuellement
c'est le bâtiment moi à ce moment-là
c'est un gros en gros un Grosso à 50 ans
le bâtiment je n'y connais rien donc
Pôle emploi je dis qu'est-ce que je vais
faire tirer des câbles électriques pour
t'aider des sacs de ciment bon c'est
tout ce que je peux faire le restant
c'est les métiers technicien que je ne
connais pas et Agent de location de
voiture bien entendu j'ai répondu
positivement en envoyant mon CV mais la
société m'a répondu pas possible
correspondait pas au profil mais ça je
le savais avant mais j'ai quand même
fait parce qu'aujourd'hui je suis
astreint malheureusement au bon vouloir
de la conseillère ou de conseiller Pôle
emploi qui me diras monsieur du jour au
lendemain la SS est fini on vous bascule
au RSA voilà et ça c'est mon angoisse
permanente ce qui est terrible c'est que
votre seul espoir aujourd'hui c'est la
retraite dans 6 ans et là au lieu
d'avoir 460 euros par mois vous en aurez
alors tous les mois vous avez entre 420
et 460 euros que l'agent du Pôle Emploi
vous attribue ou pas votre loyer vaut
460 euros donc vous mangez comment je
fais
on mange pas 3 fois par jour faut qu'on
soit bien clair
comment je fais
l'avantage d'avoir autour de moi déjà
une femme j'ai une famille
je dis ça avec un peu d'émotion mais
c'est terriblement humiliant de devoir
demander
de temps de la main sa famille si vos
enfants qui vous nourrissent aujourd'hui
oui comme ça je vous invite à dîner à
déjeuner ou il vous donne de l'argent
pour acheter à manger comment ça se
passe c'est plus sous cette forme là il
vous donne de l'argent voilà
et de la viande vous en mangez une fois
par mois vous je me suis habitué avec le
temps à
m'en défaire parce que vous refusez
d'aller au resto du coeur ah oui je me
refuse parce que c'est aujourd'hui ma
seule dignité c'est pour ça que je
m'accroche à payer rubis surnom de mon
loyer pour le restant on fait autrement
et puis
pour moi le logement c'est hyper
important parce que si je ne peux plus
bien sûr enfin si vous n'arrivez plus à
payer votre logement vous devenez SDF
quoi tout à fait alors votre vie ça se
passe comment vous levez de bonheur oui
toujours vous lever à 6h non parce que
vous vous dites je veux pas sombrer quoi
dans la dans le laisser aller c'est à
dire les chômeurs qui passent leur vie
devant la télé à rien et alors
comme vous avez pas de boulot vous
occupez beaucoup des autres oui parce
que je trouve que c'est comment
dirais-je le chômeur c'est pas le celui
qui reste au fond de son lit jusqu'à
midi c'est pas celui
qui fait rien c'est quand même des gens
actifs parce que je voudrais quand même
rappeler une chose le chômage on l'a pas
choisi on le subit c'est les chefs
d'entreprise qui licencie c'est pas les
salariés qui disent on va partir et puis
on reste on va pas se raconter
d'histoires quand on voit des
entreprises qui font des normes
bénéfices et qui licencie quand même des
gens qui produisent encore de la
richesse dans l'entreprise à leurs
actionnaires je sais bien ce qui vous
choque le plus en fait c'est l'absence
de mobilisation collective si vous vous
aidez les gens sur le plan administratif
juridique etc mais vous trouvez personne
pour faire la révolution avec vous je
crois que la Révolution
elle commence dans les urnes et je crois
qu'il y a un signal fort qui s'est fait
dernièrement parce que on a pris on a
perdu notre travail on nous fait perdre
notre dignité mais on a toujours le
droit de vote j'écoutais lundi les
chiffres de la Cour des comptes 39
milliards d'exonération fiscales et
sociales si exonération sociale ça veut
dire exonération de versement à la CAF
exonération la sécurité sociale qu'on
nous raconte pas d'histoires vous savez
ce qui est choquant l'année dernière
l'été dernier
annoncé par la presse et c'est bien que
ça se sache le président de la
République invité à Paris les chefs
d'État à 5500 euros le repas moi si vous
faites le calcul je les ai pas dans
l'année évidemment on consomme en une
heure ou deux ce que un ayant droit à SS
ou un ayant droit RSA vit un an alors
ce que je trouve extraordinaire avec
vous c'est vous continuez à vous battre
à votre place beaucoup auraient lâché
prise vous êtes veuve vous êtes à la SS
et vous continuez quand même à vous
battre c'est que je le fais pas
uniquement que pour moi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui pour mes enfants pour mes
petits-enfants pour et surtout pour les
autres parce que je fonctionne comme ça
j'ai toujours donné je continuerai à
donner donc je pourrais tenir debout
mais
je suis en résistance et je suis en
résistance pourquoi parce que la France
elle avait des valeurs il y avait un
million de précaires en France les
chiffres qu'on nous donne ils sont faux
pourquoi jeudi 20 millions de prêtres il
y a des chômeurs on donne les chiffres
qu'on a envie mais il y a les salariés
pauvres et puis les retraités on voit
plein de retraités qui arrivent en
retraite avec 500 euros et puis des
retraités et ça c'est dramatique aussi
on voit la Banque de France les
surendettement les surendettement
aujourd'hui de la grande majorité de
dossiers de surendettement c'est des
retraités qui avaient des bons revenus
sauf que ils aident leurs enfants cons
50 ans ils aident aussi de leur petit
enfant et voilà
alors le pire de tout ça c'est que ce
qui vous est arrivé peut arriver à tout
le monde c'est-à-dire un parcours
professionnel sans encombre vous n'êtes
pas un fainéant vous avez bossé vous
allez gagner jusqu'à 50000 balles par
mois donc c'est plutôt bien et
finalement tout va bien et d'un coup
c'est la descente aux enfers
c'est-à-dire que finalement la
roche-tard Payenne est pas loin du
Capitole ça peut arriver à tout le monde
aujourd'hui on a énormément de gens de
l'encadrement peu importe ingénieur
technicien cadre selon le la hauteur de
leurs ressources et de leurs
qualifications qui rejoignent les
mouvements de gens qui sont en
résistance évidemment ils se montrent
pas forcément mais on les rencontre
souvent les gens et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est quand c'est en train
de bouger il y a pas une famille en
France aujourd'hui qui ne pas qu'il a
pas connu en son sein un homme ou une
femme ou un enfant au chômage c'est tout
à fait voilà bien Jean-Luc un mot
j'aurai la main de fer
pour que ce soit les autres qui passent
à la caisse très bien un mot moins bravo
Monsieur dignité le courage j'ai entendu
le mot résistance et j'ai entendu une
image aussi terrible et que vous êtes
comme un type qui monte une un truc
d'escalade comme ça puis tous des robes
il y a plus de on peut et on glisse on
glisse on glisse
et on est tous comme vous bravo de la
leçon de courage et de dignité que vous
avez donné et de révolte bravo merci
je m'associe à ce qui a été dit mais il
y a 8 millions de personnes en France
qui vivent avec moins de 800 euros par
mois et donc c'est inimaginable
inimaginable vous seriez d'accord pour
dire on partage évidemment mais c'est
pour ça que moi je me bats aussi contre
un certain nombre de mesures qui
viennent d'être prises récemment et qui
me paraissent complètement à côté de la
plaque par rapport aux 400000 personnes
qui vont se retrouver intégralement en
fin de droit cela dit pas faire de
démagogie ce que vous avez dit très bien
vous-même monsieur c'est que ce que vous
attendez c'est pas au fond qu'on
augmente l'assistanat qu'on passe de je
sais pas quoi de 400 c'est pas ça ce que
vous voulez c'est un boulot il y a un
mot qu'on emploie plus jamais qui
pourtant est un joli mot c'est justice
sociale et oui voilà et je pense que ce
pays manque de justice sociale et je dis
pas ça pour faire plaisir à mélange
merci d'avoir été avec nous et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu